listen you understand just cuz you're a
human being doesn't mean you're entitled
to be a successful entrepreneur they do
what everybody else does in every genre
you want to be an NFL player and an NBA
player you try you're not good enough to
do something else you want to be in
famous actor you go to LA you wait
tables you try to be on a show it
doesn't happen you do something else
I don't know what they do like something
else but they're not gonna build a
million dollar business guys dearly
million dollar businesses are actually
built to sustain like the data is not in
our favor and I'm not trying to be
cloudy in this Sun I'm trying to save
people some money and some heartache and
create some upside this is just
practicality like it's it's just data
we're not talking about it and listen a
lot of you know my schpeel
I'm not excited to talk about this I'm
happy-go-lucky I'm positive I'm crushing
but I'm [ __ ] telling you the truth
it's just here right now and and what
that means by the way let me explain a
lot of the businesses that actually can
be successful the problem is you have 17
employees when you should have 5 a lot
of young businesses that can be
successful but you want to have a nice
office right and so how instead of being
somewhere shitty right like a lot of you
can have businesses that are successful
but you come to [ __ ] waste time
instead of building your business
that last part and all the other [ __ ]
like are you building a business like
you better [ __ ] work tomorrow and the
only reason some of you will is is
because it's going to rain because if it
was like this today tomorrow you'd all
be somewhere and and that's just losing
and that's happening at scale of course
and by the way a good percentage of them
are gonna win I hope you're sitting
there and getting mad at me and saying
[ __ ] this guy and I can't wait to get
your email saying oh you said I wasn't
gonna win a propeller
I built a hundred million dollar
business respect great I want that I
hope every [ __ ] person looking at my
face right now wins everything money
life health great I want that more than
anybody why not be the greatest I just
think there's an enormous lack of
practicality right now
moving in that was positive that was the
positive direction
that was awesome
I think that's positive instead of
people pontificating here like yeah
we're all gonna [ __ ] do it